the committee investigating the January
the sixth riots last year in Washington
has voted to subpoena the former
president Donald Trump requiring him to
appear before them Skies James Matthews
is in Washington with the latest uh well
tell us about this decision Jones
yeah thanks Tom at the big finish at uh
what has been scheduled as a final
hearing of this Congressional committee
they have voted to subpoena the former
president Donald Trump they have been
hearing over the course of four months
of course a pool together or the events
surrounding the attack on the capital on
January the 6th last year what we heard
today was effectively a pool together of
what happened and Trump's role in the
attack on the capital the point being
made by each individual representative
on this committee was that he was across
all the detail and he was very much
pulling the strings Behind These very
violent events it in terms of the run-up
to January the 6th he simply wouldn't
accept
the decision of the American public in
the 2020 election long before that
election he was shaping up to reject it
as a fraud that Julian sued we're
looking at footage now Dermot of the
assaults by the mob on the capital we
saw new footage today which was quite
compelling it showed the mob outside
storming the building but also it gave
us a new insight into the plight of
those who are inside the politicians
Nancy Pelosi Speaker of the House of
Representatives Chuck Schumer Democratic
leader in the Senate and so on trying to
protect themselves and also trying to
protect their government essentially and
to hold back the writers and any
influence they may have on the political
system at that particular point but yeah
essentially the uh the big highlight of
this hearing presented by this committee
is the bit to subpoena Donald Trump it's
something of course that he may reject
indeed that wouldn't be a surprise he
has dismissed this as a politically
motivated Witch Hunt a familiar refrain
from the former president but you know
he's legally bound to respond positively
Steve Bannon one of his former aides has
been subpoenaed he didn't turn up and he
has since been convicted of contempt of
congress for so doing so it's
interesting it's another
piece of legal Jeopardy faced by Donald
Trump we have of course documents found
at Mar-A-Lago events in Georgia with
regard
to his undue influence or attended on
due influence over the results there
during the election so you know he's
fighting legal fires and this clearly
adds considerably to those